foreign
[Music]
what's going on your father Jacob
Holbrook when was the last time you
spoke to him when I was 10 years old I'm
confused I thought your parents died in
a car accident
to you
Holbrook he's the marsh King guy that I
heard about on the radio he and another
prisoner escaped last night
Wilderness with the daughter she gave
birth to while in captivity hope I'm not
trespassing or anything
[Applause]
I think he's coming for me
I wish he would have told me the truth
he gave me this after my first kill
these were the only tears my father ever
wanted to see you'll always be my little
Shadow now I realized a person I
believed in the most was really a
monster this means we're family
and means owned not family don't confuse
the two
[Music]
has that been in your room the whole
time
you must always protect your family
[Music]
it's me
that's where we belong
I waited my whole life to see you again
I wasn't sure what I would feel when I
did
[Music]
you can still all be your family
oh